monsieur bonsoir algérie référendum le 3
novembre prochain pour modifier la
constitution à l'assemblée nationale
roland dumas exprime la solidarité de la
france
le sud-est sous l'orage deux enfants
étouffée par la boue la nuit dernière en
ardèche
le plan orsec maintenu dans le gard la
chute de la banque de commerce et de
crédit international pour la première
fois des banquiers de haut vol tombe
pour avoir blanchi l'argent de la drogue
ils dormaient dans leur chambre du
pavillon familial auteuil ils étaient
frères et soeurs il avait 13 et 9 ans
ils sont morts étouffés par un torrent
de boue qui dévalait la colline cela
s'est passé hier soir en ardèche de mort
donc a disparu un blessé grave des
maisons inondées des routes coupées
tout le sud est de la france a été
battue par des pluies diluviennes qui
ont gonflé fleuves et rivières
le plan orsec est toujours déployée dans
le gard et une cellule de crise a été
mise en place à la préfecture de l'isère
claude réjean des pluies torrentielles
sur un terrain escarpé
c'est l'explication du drame qui a
provoqué la mort de nathalie et ludovic
dans leur maison familiale du theil un
pan de la colline a glissé la boue a
emporté leur chambre ils ont été
ensevelis carrément parle par la boue
est pas allé par les débris de deux murs
et des dards mollahs plus au sud au bord
de l'ardèche un jeune homme a été
emporté par les eaux d'un torrent après
la rupture de cette berge
ils tentaient de secourir les occupants
de ces caravanes surpris par la brutale
montée les aux jeunes qui vit à saint
martin a voulu aller
leur idée et se noyer il a été emporté
par le courant du ruisseau pas de leurs
déchets ces pluies très violentes
rappel le phénomène climatique connue il
y a dix jours à nîmes le nord de l'isère
a subit lui aussi des trombes d'eau la
nuit dernière ainsi à bourgoin jallieu
la bourbre est sortie de son lit
la circulation automobile a été coupée
le grande partie de la matinée sur
l'autoroute lyon grenoble ce soir encore
la liaison ferroviaire n'était pas
rétabli entre les deux villes
laurent cabrol nous en dira plus tout à
l'heure mais de nouveaux orages sont à
craindre demain et la fin de la semaine
pourrait être pire encore dans les
régions sud-est l'algérois se calment la
kabylie s'embrase
comme prévu l'état de siège a été
officiellement levé ce matin à alger
mais à tizi ouzou de violents
affrontements ont eu lieu cet après-midi
entre des manifestants hostiles au
régime et ceux qui exprimaient leur
soutien au président chadli les forces
de l'ordre sont intervenues le sang dans
la rue pourtant fait bouger le régime
algérien à alger ce soit la présidence a
annoncé deux référendum populaire
un premier le 3 novembre prochain qui
modifiera la constitution et rendra le
gouvernement responsable devant
l'assemblée un second quelques semaines
plus tard qui entérinera ou non les
réformes politiques sur lequel se sera
accordée le congrès national du parti
unique
d'ici là les tensions seront rudes
sûrement entre réformistes et
conservateurs
journée calme alger où pourtant l'armée
et les chats restent très présents le
compte rendu dès l'aube de jacques
merlino et jean cornil 6 heures du matin
en plein coeur d'alger couvre feu et est
à deux sièges viennent d'être levée
voici la première image du retour à une
vie normale
côte à côte au bar les policiers
mitraillette en bandoulière boivent leur
café avec ceux qui sans doute lié encore
participé aux manifestations
la nuit a été calme trouvait seulement
par le bruit des convois militaires
quittant la capitale et ce matin nous
avons pu constater que le dispositif
militaire était considérablement
allégées sans être complètement supprimé
environ 1 charge sur trois est encore en
position mais les soldats semblent
beaucoup plus détendue et bart avec les
passants les services de nettoyage au
travail et rapidement il n'y a plus de
carcasses de voitures brûlées et les
restes des barricades ont été balayées
les algériens avec lesquels nous avons
bavardé ce matin nous ont exprimé leur
confiance dans ce retour au calme
comme si rien
ouais
ouais ça va
en course a repris comme d'habitude on
en reverra secteur
voyez les clients
j'aime bien les gens y sont guère
nombreuses arrestations ont été
effectuées hier et nous fortes
inquiétudes subsistent dans les milieux
intellectuels
tous demandent que soit assurée de
meilleures garanties de justice oui des
arrestations ce serait donc multipliés
ces derniers jours dans les dans des
milieux très divers intellectuels mais
aussi membre de la ligue des droits de
l'homme et frères musulmans les
autorités restent muettes sur la
question alger comme à oran la
population qui ne peut pas compter ses
morts et récupérer leurs dépouilles et
traumatisé martin laroche joubert après
les émeutes d'oran lune et surtout par
les enfants et les adolescents
vient maintenant le temps des
arrestations plusieurs centaines aussi
difficile d'évaluer le nombre des morts
une quarantaine peut-être l'armée refuse
pour le moment de rendre les corps aux
familles on les a vus à l'hôpital et est
avait il y avait des gens de 17 ans et
des enfants de 17 ans et même des moins
que ça c'est à dire quatre en huit ans
touché par balle et ça a été un
véritable massacre
là je suis sûre que toutes les mères de
famille sont d'accord avec moi c'est
difficilement acceptable
et vous pensez que le vix show cars ont
séché n'y va régler à aider ces mères de
familles qui ont perdu leurs enfants
la perte dallas enfants ne se laissent
pas facilement pas même avec un discours
présidentiel le quotidien officiel
algérien el moudjahid s'en prend les
violences aujourd'hui aux journalistes
occidentaux coupable selon lui de mener
une entreprise de désinformation et
d'intoxication haineuse depuis une
semaine
l'ambassadeur de france a été convoqué
au ministère algérien des affaires
étrangères pour entendre les
protestations officielles
après les propos pourtant bien mesuré
tenu hier soir par le ministre de la
coopération jacques pelletier qui
parlait d'une révolte des jeunes contre
le manque de démocratie
c'est dire l'extrême susceptibilité des
autorités algériennes à l'égard de ce
qui est dit à paris c'est dire aussi
l'extrême prudence du gouvernement
français qui s'est enfin exprimé tout à
l'heure à l'assemblée nationale par la
voix du ministre des affaires étrangères
roland dumas
la france at il dit en substance se doit
de marquer sa solidarité avec l'algérie
et chaque terme de son allocution était
pesé jean-louis le sel il aura fallu
attendre dix jours de troubles en
algérie pour que la représentation
nationale se saisisse enfin du dossier
par le biais des questions d'actualité
premier à monter au créneau un homme qui
s'est fait connaître pour sa défense des
droits de l'homme qu'est ce que le
gouvernement français compte dire effet
dit il
et je précise de façon à ce que les
choses soient claires que je ne crois
pas que la règle puisse être content des
leçons quand c'est loin et qu on se tait
quand c'est prêt
malgré la précision de la question la
réponse sera un peu plus diplomatique
nous espérons que les réponses annoncées
apporteront le soulagement attendu mais
il reste que la communauté
internationale et à commencer par la
france se doit de marquer sa solidarité
avec l'algérie en étant dans cette
période si difficile le gouvernement et
pouvoir et par la voix de leur président
louis mermaz les socialistes eux-mêmes
reviendront à la charge et ils
hésiteront applaudir la réponse du
ministre dans les couloirs personne
n'est content à commencer par les
socialistes
rien absolument rien ne peut expliquer
n'est justifié cette attitude
ce sont des actes qu'il faut condamner
nous sommes un peu surpris qu'il n'y ait
pas eu une réponse plus net de la part
du gouvernement
je pense que le gouvernement doit lui
aussi avec beaucoup de fermeté
faire appel à l'esprit de tolérance sont
pourtant en effet s'ingérer dans les
affaires qui sont des affaires
extérieures à notre pays je pense le
gouvernement français doit se sentir
particulièrement appelé à aider à la
réussite des réformes que va tenter le
gouvernement algérien tant d'années
après il est curieux de constater qu'à
l'assemblée nationale le simple fait
d'évoquer l'algérie trouble toujours
autant l'ensemble de la classe politique
française et ce soir à l'issue de son
bureau exécutif le parti socialiste
exprime par la voix de pierre mauroy
quelques nuances par rapport à la
position officielle du gouvernement
entre nos deux peuples
nous souhaitons que les autorités
algériennes trouve la voie de
l'apaisement
le parti socialiste suivre avec
vigilance le sort qui sera fait aux
centaines de personnes arrêtées
c'est en répondant aux revendications
légitimes de la population que la
société algérienne se préservera au
mieux des excès des aventures évoluera
vers des pratiques démocratiques et un
développement nécessaire
la gauche se prépare aux municipales le
parti communiste a accepté ce soir le
principe d'une rencontre proposée par le
parti socialiste qui s'était ému du
comportement communiste lors des
élections cantonales à l'assemblée
nationale ce soir les députés devraient
à la quasi-unanimité adopté le premier
grand projet social du gouvernement il
s'agit du revenu minimum d'insertion
le texte initial a dû être révisé
plusieurs fois à la demande des députés
socialistes en conseil des ministres ce
matin plusieurs projets ont été adoptés
qui dans des domaines très différents
seront mises en application
prochainement commençons par les mesures
qui vont être prises en faveur des
personnes âgées
l'objectif prioritaire du ministre théo
braun et d'améliorer dans une société où
les familles sont de plus en plus
éclatées et parfois même indifférente
d'améliorer la prise en charge des
vieillards une pratique se développe qui
est celle des familles d'accueil et
qu'une loi devra bientôt réglementée eve
n'était pas fragile en plus simple elles
sont trois 3 personnes âgés de 58 à 87
ans à vivre au domicile de monsieur
madame brouille est appelée dans la
sarthe
l'une a été confiée ici par sa propre
famille les deux autres par l'hôpital de
château du loir qui jugeait inutile la
poursuite de leur hospitalisation
claude rouiller est au chômage ils
touchent l'allocation fin de droits soit
environ 2000 francs par mois
l'accueil des trois personnes âgées
apporte à la famille treize mille deux
cents francs supplémentaires on line pas
ils brûlent pas pour nous ça nous permet
quand même de le joindre les deux bouts
étant donné que mon mari est au chômage
et que bon il fallait qu'on travaille
fait les quelques axes de travail
finalement un bon ben si bien que ça
nous permet de faire mais sur des
petites choses qu'on n'aurait peut-être
pas pu faire autrement mais ça me donne
du temps du travail aussi parce que
trois personnes c'est quand même de
l'occupation là en ce moment j'en ai eu
qu il faut que je lui donne à manger
parce qu'elle peut pas marcher en ce
moment donc pour lui donne à manger
matin midi soir montrouge la lave faut
que faut que je passe tout finalement
les trois pensionnaires de monsieur
madame brouillé se disent bien soigné
même si certaines semblent subir la
situation plutôt que l'avoir choisi j'ai
retrouvé une famille c'est très bien je
me sens revivre c'est le cas de dire je
crois que c'est la première fois dans
l'existence que je je suis aussi
tranquille c'est vous qui avez décidé
d'être ici un match évident à mes
enfants qui s'occupe de sadara je m'en
fiche
vous avez retrouvé une famille c'est une
pub mais ce n'est pas comme si longtemps
a sonné ça ne fait pas pareil je prends
ma chance
quelques centaines de familles en france
accueille aujourd'hui des personnes
âgées moyennant finances
le gouvernement entend développer la
formule et la réglementer pour éviter
certains abus autre projet adopté ce
matin en conseil des ministres celui
d'une nouvelle loi sur l'audiovisuel qui
va instituer un conseil supérieur à la
place de l'actuel cncl le futur csa sera
composé de neuf membres de moins de 65
ans désigné par le président de la
république le président du sénat et
celui de l'assemblée nationale ils
auront des pouvoirs et des moyens accrus
notamment en matière de sanction
la création de cette nouvelle instance
ne mettra pas fin au mandat des
présidents des chaînes publiques at il
été précisé
pour françois léotard qui avait signé la
loi précédente
le processus de nomination des membres
constitue un authentique recours retour
en arrière
troisième projet adopté ce matin celui
là à l'initiative de roger bambuck
anciens champions olympiques et
secrétaire d'état aux sports un projet
de loi sur le dopage
l'objectif au-delà des sanctions et des
contrôles incité le mouvement sportif
dans son ensemble à prendre ses
responsabilités et transport de plus
vont faire l'objet de contrôles
le tennis les courses automobiles et le
football jean mamère dopage dégage c'est
donc ce que souhaite le ministre des
sports et ce dans toutes les fédérations
quelques-unes comme celle du tennis se
pas toujours senti concerné vraiment par
ce phénomène d'autres comme le football
sans montre un enthousiasme débordant se
sont pliés aux contrôles à la fin de
quelques rencontres internationales mais
elles n'ont jamais voulu se pencher
vraiment sur le problème retranchée
derrière l'argument du sport collectif
qui masquer les carences individuelles
le football moderne est pourtant devenu
exigeant pour l'organisme il peut
justifier lui aussi le contrôle inopiné
à la fin d'un entraînement
moi je suis totalement d'accord c'est
bon c'est sûr que ça demandera beaucoup
de crédit beaucoup d'efforts de la part
des uns et des autres mais si ça peut
enlever toute suspicion et puis si ça
peut permettre aux jeunes de voir que
les athlètes de haut niveau sont des
performances en étant sain de corps et
d'esprit
il faut le faire autre cible
l'automobile jouer avec sa vie à 300
km/heure haute a priori toute idée de
dopage c'est un pilote et pourtant la
suspicion règne ce dr allemand qui suit
de très près certains pilotes est
suspect les faiblesses répétés sur un
podium du britannique nigel mansell
comme ici à brands hatch en 87 ont jeté
la suspicion
néanmoins la fédération internationale
reste de marbre
tout en s'avouant vigilante quant à la
fédération française qui a d'ailleurs le
même président elle rejette toute
accusation de non collaboration
il ya eu sept contrôles antidopage cette
année sur le plan de la fédération
française et tous qui ont été faits de
façon inattendue
absolument donc au plan français nous
appliquons totalement des directives du
ministre c'est un bon point mais le
nettoyage complet n'est pas encore pour
demain
gare aux embouteillages demain à paris
près entre les grèves et la main et les
manifestations
a la ratp les négociations direction
intersyndicale ont échoué le trafic a
été à nouveau perturbé aujourd'hui à
l'appel de la cgt sur la ligne a du rer
et des préavis de grève ont été déposés
pour demain et vendredi sur les lignes a
et b
prenez donc vos précautions si vous êtes
concerné les infirmières défileront à
nouveau demain en deux formations
distinctes celle de la coordination et
celle des syndicats
si les manifestations sont terminées les
négociations au ministère de la santé
devrait reprendre demain soir
manifestation encore à paris de la
république à la nation
solidarité avec le peuple algérien à
l'appel d'une vingtaine d'organisations
politiques syndicales et humanitaires
donc demain los angeles 6 tonnes de
drogue saisies d'un coup valeur près
d'un milliard et demi de francs
huit colombiens ont été arrêtés sans
doute les sbires du fameux cartel de
medellin
mais c'est une autre prise qui mérite ce
soir qu'on s'y arrête en détail car il
s'agit véritablement d'un triomphe dans
la lutte à possible contre l' empire de
la drogue pour la première fois une
banque tout entière et non des moindres
est officiellement accusé d'avoir
consacré l'essentiel de ses activités à
blanchir l'argent récolté en masse par
les trafiquants de drogue
90 personnes inculpées en france aux
états unis en grande bretagne
quarante autres arrêtés aux états unis
en grande bretagne en argentine
deux enquêtes menées en collaboration
étroite par les douanes américaines
britanniques et françaises
toute la rédaction d'antenne 2 à paris
et à l'étranger s'est mobilisée pour
vous raconter cette énorme affaire aux
ressorts de feuilletons tête baissée
menottes aux poignets ces hommes sont
des banquiers pas tout à fait comme les
autres leur banque une blanchisserie
plutôt servait à recycler l'argent sale
l'argent de la drogue celui des
trafiquants colombiens cartel de
medellin
un nom associé au plus gigantesque
trafic de cocaïne de la planète
le problème de ces trafiquants n'ont pas
l'écoulement de la drogue mais
l'écoulement de l'argent il leur faut
alors trouver une banque qui accepte de
fermer les yeux sur l'origine de ces
millions de dollars et c'est là qu'entre
en scène la bci société anonyme créée en
1972 par des pakistanais
elle est aujourd'hui la 7ème
institutions financières privées au
monde
derrière cette façade un centre
administratif les employés se taisent le
gouvernement luxembourgeois affirme
qu'aucun argent doute n'est passé par
l'abbé cci dans ce grand duché souvent
synonyme de paradis fiscal
le secret bancaire existe mais
officiellement aucun compte des anonymes
d'argent de la cocaïne serait donc
ailleurs dans une des 32 filiale celle
de miami qui dépend des îles caïmans à
paris ou à londres à paris les trois
dirigeants de la filiale française ont
été arrêtés après plusieurs mois
d'enquêté menée par les douaniers
alertés par leurs collègues américains
des saisies ont donc été effectués par
les services des enquêtes douanières qui
ont porté sur un certain nombre de deux
comptes de dépôt de dossiers bancaires
qui représentent environ une
cinquantaine de kilos et dix sont
actuellement en cours d'exploitation
les documents saisis prouve notamment
que plusieurs comptes de clients
étrangers
servette au recyclage de l'argent d'un
membre ces deux hommes messieurs barak
sari ali akbar ont été mis à la
disposition de la justice
l'un comme l'autre travaillé pour la
banque de crédit et de commerce
international la banque de crédit et de
commerce international à londres
comprend 29 agences servant surtout la
nombreuse communauté asiatique
elle s'est développée si rapidement en
disant que la banque d'angleterre sonné
l'alarmé
la filiale anglaise de la bci at elle
joué un rôle particulier dans ce
blanchissage de l'argent de la drogue
on n'en sait rien ce que l'on sait c'est
que les douaniers américains sont venus
souvent ici à londres et se sont
intéressés de très près à ce qu'ils
passent et en grande bretagne
william banderas patron des douanes
américaines explique carte à l'appui le
mécanisme de l'opération seacret pendant
deux ans ces agents se faisant passer
pour des trafiquants de drogue ont
organisé sans deux transferts de fonds
pour un total de 32 millions de dollars
sur les comptes de la bcc à tampa en
floride puis au panama
une piste qui conduit directement au
général manuel noriega homme fort du
panama la bête noire de la justice
américaine noriega est d'ailleurs
inculpé en floride pour ses liens avec
le cartel de medellin
les pourvoyeurs de la cocaïne en
colombie c'est un succès unique par son
ampleur
surtout il couronne une coopération sans
précédent entre services américains
britanniques et français
je suis très fier de mes douaniers a
déclaré tout à l'heure le ministre du
budget michel charasse a ajouté avec la
verdeur de langage qu'on lui connaît les
mecs qui empoisonne la jeunesse avec la
drogue qui se font du fric là dessus on
va la leur faire bouffer at il dit
monsieur leroy le soleurois bonsoir vous
êtes juge d'instruction au tribunal
d'evry vous êtes l'un des meilleurs
spécialistes français en matière de
trafic de drogue
alors expliquez nous le blanchissement
de l'argent c'est bien devenu le
principal problème des trafiquants
absolument notamment pour les
trafiquants de cocaïne
vous savez qu'après avoir saturé le nom
dans le sac sont les trafiquants de
cocaïne s'intéresse à la france et aux
pays latin parce que ils ont remarqué
qu'il y avait un marché potentiel
considérable et d'autre part ils ont
remarqué certaines faiblesses d'une au
système bancaire qui permettent
justement
facilement ce blanchissement d'autre
part nous avons chez nous un milieu qui
est intéressé dans la mesure où il
achète 80 mille francs le kilo de
cocaïne qu'après coupage
il peut revendre jusqu'à deux milliards
de centimes
donc nous avons actuellement un
phénomène qui ne va probablement qui ne
va cesser de croître dans les temps qui
viennent alors dans un contexte
d'ailleurs d'autant plus préoccupant si
l'on se réfère à ce qu'on a vu aux états
unis car le milieu colombien qui est
très structuré s'intéresse aux pays
comme la france ou le milieu ne l'est
pas on a vu par exemple qu'en italie il
ya une forte résistance de la mafia qui
empêche leur implantation
or la mafia vieillissante américaine n'a
pas su leur résister et je crains que le
milieu français qui est en pleine
restructuration se trouve dans la même
situation
alors est ce que ça veut dire monsieur
le juge on peut s'attendre en france à
de nouvelles affaires de ce genre et
peut-être de cette ampleur
alors oui à la fois parce que notre
législation maintenant réprime le
blanchissement de la drogue le concours
à les opérations de placement de
dissimulation de conversion du produit
du trafic la facilitation de la
justification mensongères de l'origine
des fonds cela fait encourir 2 à 10 ans
de prison
et d'autre part nous constatons que des
trafiquants
de notre pays qui achètent par exemple
100 kg de cocaïne pour 800 millions de
centimes doivent faire passer une telle
somme en amérique du sud
ils ont remarqué que des pays comme le
luxembourg la belgique ou l'espagne ont
un système bancaire qui permet des
opérations relativement facile alors ces
trafiquants s'intéresse à la fois au
système boursier
le site italien de change et des deux
soldats les placements bancaires et
enfin il utilise le système dit des
banques offshore qui sont des banques
qui ont pour caractéristique de ne pas
dépendre de la législation du pays où
ils se trouvent
exemple jersey les bahamas les îles
caïmans etc toute l'astuce consiste donc
à démarrer à partir de pays comme le
luxembourg et ensuite à multiplier les
transferts d'une banque à l'autre à
travers le système offshore pour
compliquer les recherches alors de plus
au niveau des banques luxembourgeoises
par exemple ils utilisent la création au
coup par coup de sociétés dites
d'import-export où ils ont recours à des
personnes qui sert de prête-nom
messieurs le juge merci pour ces
précisions passionnante qui prouve à
quel point ce trafic est devenu d'une
extrême sophistication en corse
l'assemblée régionale siège depuis hier
au moment où vous le savez le comité
interministériel mis en place par le
gouvernement doit entreprendre le
développement à long terme de lille les
parlementaires corses ont examiné
aujourd'hui un projet précis qui
illustre bien les difficultés des
accords locaux dominique verdeilhan au
sud de bastia
l'étang de biguglia 15 cents hectares
aujourd'hui à l'abandon sont l'objet de
bien des convoitises celles
d'entrepreneurs locaux comme ici paul
natali
son ambition faire de ce cordon
lagunaire à nouveau port grimaud son
objectif à moyen terme
trente mille lits et l'implantation de
nombreuses pme un projet éloigné de
celui qu'ambitionne la région qui
souhaitent acheter le terrain pour en
faire une réserve naturelle protégée un
terrain mis à prix 15 e
en francs mais c'est la société
italienne pirelli qui pourrait le 20
octobre prochain
emporter le morceau l'italie par où
arrive aujourd'hui plus de passagers
européens que par la france nous
l'urgence dans la perspective européenne
de 93 d'élaborer un plan global de
développement et un schéma d'aménagement
de l'île et mab development pas rien ne
pourra se faire encore du poids de
l'activité économique
top alors pas régler le problème des
transports est en colère pas réglé celui
de l'infrastructure hôtelière ça c'est
clair développement oui tourisme oui
mais pour les nationalistes pas à
n'importe quel prix
aujourd'hui on considère notre vie comme
zone de consommation auront fait un
bronze aux drones de l'europe où seront
peut-être un peuple de barman un peuple
de caddie pour certains golfs et nous
nous avons une autre ambition pour notre
pays pour notre jeunesse que d'être des
jambes de plus en plus marginalisée sur
notre propre sol ou jour géré nos
affaires
agacé par un certain immobilisme par une
certaine lenteur chez les élus corses
le gouvernement a donné à l'assemblée
régionale jusqu'à la fin de l'année pour
l'établissement de ce schéma menaçant
sinon de prendre le dossier en main ce
développement économique nécessite des
hommes des hommes nous enlèverons ils
sont à l'extérieur qu'ils soient corse
d'ailleurs ou continentaux il faut donc
inciter les gens à revenir sur place le
plan développement économique devait
apporter dans ce pays la paix civile
et si la paix civile et lisent dans ce
pays aucune raison au absolument aucune
raison que ceux qui ne se développe pas
paix civile
prev des mots qui depuis plus de quatre
mois font que les corses vivent en état
de grâce
la faire des fausses factures du parti
socialiste dans le rhône une ordonnance
de non lieu a été rendue aujourd'hui
emmanuel vanier fin des poursuites
entreprises et contre deux responsables
du parti socialiste du rhône
yvon deschamps et françois diaz les dix
hommes avait été accusé il ya un an
d'avoir utilisé des fausses factures
d'un montant de 800 mille francs pour
financer la campagne des élections
législatives
jacques amis juge d'instruction a estimé
que ces infractions devait être amnistié
après la loi de juillet dernier il a
donc prononcé le non lieu
cependant un autre juge d'instruction
lyonnais georges fenech affirme détenir
des documents qui lui permettrait de
maintenir l'inculpation des deux
responsables du ps robert del pub s'est
suicidé dans sa cellule de la prison de
clermont ferrand et hier soir le
meurtrier présumé de ludivine 9 ans
violée et tuée en septembre dernier
s'est pendu en accrochant un drap aux
barreaux
robert delpire avait été isolée après
les menaces de mort émanant des autres
prisonniers
il devait être transféré aujourd'hui
même dans une prison plus moderne et
plus adaptée à son cas
huit mois de prison avec sursis et 20
mille francs d'amendé pour fraude
fiscale
anthony delon avait oublié de déclarer
ses revenus en 83 84 85
le fisc alerté par le train de vie dorée
du jeune homme lui réclamé 800 mille
francs les magistrats ont donc été
beaucoup plus clément ils ont estimé qu
anthony étaient si jeunes au moment des
faits que cela pouvait constituer une
circonstance atténuante
c'est une lune de miel qui règne
désormais entre paris et moscou en
croire les ministres des affaires
étrangères soviétique et français à
l'issue de la visite officielle à paris
d' edouard chevardnadzé plusieurs
dossiers importants ont été examinés et
les positions se sont rapprochées sur le
désarmement les conflits régionaux et
les relations culturelles comme les deux
ministres l'ont expliqué tout à l'heure
lors d'une conférence de presse monsieur
chez barnes est reparti ce soir pour
moscou
en tout cas la culture soviétique est à
l'honneur à paris ces temps ci à
l'invitation du festival d'automne
quatre troupes de théâtre de moscou et
de leningrad les meilleurs du pays sont
en représentation notamment le théâtre
d'art de moscou l'équivalent de notre
comédie française michel serait le vichy
et noël alexandre ont suivi avec efremov
répétant l'oncle vania de tchekhov voici
l'avant-garde de la rue et russes sur
paris un déferlement de plusieurs
centaines d'acteurs metteur en scène
cinéastes écrivains musiciens venus de
moscou nous présenter le visage de la
culture pérestroïka du jamais vu oleg
efremov et son théâtre d'art ouvre le
bal avec tchekhov
l'écrivain qui a érigé les gens simples
en héros du drame
ce choix ne doit rien au hasard pour les
partisans du nouveau cours de l'histoire
soviétique un symbole à la mesure des
frais mof lui-même ce créateur pendant
30 ans en lutte contre le glacis des
bureaucrates
tavant gorbatchev la liberté de création
était des plus difficiles toshi aller
pour créer surmonté de très nombreux
problèmes mais il s'avère que la liberté
est encore plus difficile maintenant il
faut répondre par soi même de tourner
cette responsabilité cette liberté
elle n'est pas facile à assumer un
directeur de troupe héros de la
pérestroïka rien d'étonnant en russie le
miroir de la société de ses problèmes de
son degré de liberté c'est le théâtre à
moscou quand le théâtre va tout va
parcours obligé de ses ambassadeurs d'un
type nouveau
la tour eiffel mais l'inédit sait
l'importance désormais accordée à ce
lieu symbolique le parvis du trocadéro
le parvis des droits de l'homme et des
libertés
vous savez que chez nous c'est la glace
nost et la paire est strict
nous espérons nous faisons tout pour que
nous aussi enfin nous puissions profiter
de toutes les libertés est présumé et
les cfa va
toutes les montres sont elles à l'heure
de la pérestroïka à moscou ces acteurs
sont un des moments de la bataille en
coup de l'émotion et de l'oxygène demain
matin au plus tôt peut ête oxygène avec
roger zabel en direct dans télématin
didier regnier qui déjà à 8000 mètres
d'altitude dans le massif de l'everest
nous fera vivre donc en direct la
dernière étape de l'ascension des deux
guides français de l'expédition sa gamme
en retard un rendez-vous à ne pas
manquer donc demain dans télématin
voilà rapidement les pronostics de
pierrette brès pour le quarté de demain
à evry vous allez les découvrir sur
votre écran les voici le 13 le 2 le 3 le
9 le 4,8
le 11 et le 12 à 23h20 vous avez rendez
vous avec henri sannier pour notre
dernier journal demain donc 6h45 roger
zabel et toute l'équipe de télématin
dans un instant le temps avec laurent
cabrol merci d'avoir suivi ce journal à
demain 20 heures